في غضون ذلك قال مناسب الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كربي ان وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه
ستصنف ميليشيا فاجمالا الروسيه منظمه
اجراميه
الرئيس
اوكرانيا بالرغم من التوترات المتزايده
بين الجيش الروسي
يعتمد بشكل اكبر على قوه فاجنر التي
يمتلكها يبكي زين من اجل الدعم العسكري
لاحظنا مؤشرات بما فيها معلومات
استخباراتيه على زياده التوتر بين الجيش
الروسي فاجنر التي اصبحت مركز قوه
المنافسا للجيش الروسي ووزارات روسيه اخرى
في اوكرانيا ويتخذ قرارات عسكريه تستند
الى حد كبير الى النتائج التي ستحدثها
قوته من اجل الدعايه الايجابيه لصالحه
ما يقرب من 50,000 عنصر منتشرين في
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك 10,000 متعاقد
و40,000 مجرم بحسب تقييماتنا ونتوقع ان
تستمر في التجنيد من السجون الروسيه